Pues el ambiente pudiera resumirlo en
dos palabras indignación y determinación
ya han comenzado a llegar aquí en la
plaza de Italia en el sureste de país
del de París Perdón varios cientos de
personas en respuesta a esa convocatoria
de los sindicatos que ya mencionabas hay
representatividad pudiera decir desde
todas las generaciones aquí al llegar
conversé con dos estudiantes
universitarias que me comentaban que
están evidentemente en contra de el
proyecto de reforma de pensiones pero
que su principal motivación para estar
aquí es la aprobación por la fuerza de
esa iniciativa del presidente Emmanuel
macron me preguntaba ella hoy es la
reforma de pensiones pero mañana puede
ser cualquiera de los componentes de
nuestra seguridad social cualquier otra
conquista social por lo tanto es
necesario parar lo que está haciendo
este gobierno de inmediato conversé
también con una educadora de niños
pequeños ella me comentaba que con los
dolores de espalda que tiene es algo muy
práctico y pero pero importante de saber
ella me decía que con los dolores de
espalda que tiene no podrá llegar a los
64 años cuidando niños y Será muy tarde
para ellas reconvertirse como propone
también el presidente Emmanuel macrón
sobre el futuro de esta movilización yo
pudiera decir tengo la impresión también
hemos hablado con varias personas que
personas que nos lo comentan esta
aprobación a la fuerza ha sido un
catalizador del movimiento vimos quizás
en algún momento pusimos en cuestión en
tela de juicio la capacidad de
movilización de los sindicatos el pasado
miércoles y es realmente lo que estamos
viendo hoy la movilización en todo el
país ciertamente en algunos casos con
violencia todo parece indicar que
comienza a revivir esa este movimiento
contra la reforma de pensiones y contra
el gobierno de Manuel macrón y Luis
Miguel como usted le usted le decía no
esta activación del 49.3 ha sido un
catalizador en muchos sectores Y es que
precisamente la indignación no solo se
expresa en forma de manifestaciones en
la capital o en otras ciudades sino
también en el cese de actividades la
suspensión de actividades en sectores
tan cruciales como la refinerías por
ejemplo
hay sectores vitales para el
funcionamiento del país en huelga por
ejemplo la mayor refinería del país la
de normandía de total Energy comenzó ya
el proceso para su paralización total y
de aquí al lunes se debería sumar
también las refinería de el sur de
Francia de la costa mediterránea esto es
evidentemente es vital para el
funcionamiento del país sabemos que
también hay bloqueos en varios depósitos
de petróleo que el gobierno se muestra
desafiante porque ha dicho que si esto
sucede si es efectiva esa paralización
total van a intervenir las instalaciones
y también las personas que las operan en
el sector del transporte también se ha
sentido esta movilización se ha
respondido de forma positiva a este
llamado de la intersindical hay cerca de
300 vuelos perdón 30% de los vuelos
suspendidos a petición de las
organizaciones de la Aviación civil hay
también profesores que van a negarse a
cuidar los exámenes de ba chillerato que
son la semana próxima el Back que es una
que es toda una institución francesa y
por supuesto también esas Diez mil
toneladas de basura aquí en la ciudad de
París que permanecen sin recoger todavía
por la huelga de los recolectores de
basura y el bloqueo de Los incineradores
cercanos a la capital francesa